I'm Nick Cohen, I'm a journalist and the observer.
I write books and lots of other papers as well.
My name is Peter Gagan on I'm investigations, editor, open democracy,
and I'm the author of democracy for sale, dark money on dirty politics,
which is I would head, is this.
Right pizza? Um, it's a, it's a really impressive book before I go any further.
And I recommend everyone. Everyone gets a copy.
Can you perhaps tell viewers
your basic thesis, your,
your basic concern before we start looking into details and
solutions?
Basically my book is all about the rise of what I'm calling dark money,
but what I mean by that is kind of unaccountable money and influence lobbying,
and even Daysha and the internet in British politics.
And I'm looking at basically my argument is that British politics has
fundamentally changed in recent years because we're seeing increasing froze of
just basically of dark money in different ways, money. Um,
in terms of political donations is becoming more of a feature of our politics.
Lobbying is becoming increasingly it'll pay, can hire to hard to follow,
and actually really,
really fundamentally the interests also really change our politics and American,
not all of our rules and our laws around how we do politics,
how our democracy is protected are already for digital or for an analog era.
They're all out of date and we're living in a digital age and that our
politicians don't seem to want to grapple with the complicated,
difficult reality of just how really corroded and broken our electoral system.
I suppose someone, uh, coming this a fresh could say, well,
hold on a second piece. Yeah, yeah.
We're not remotely like an Erica where there's no limits at all Supreme court
bench pose any limits on political funding. There, there are laws,
there are, uh, caps and limits and registers of interest.
Surely this is, this is quite a tight system.
Serious. It is. And it was for a very long time. I actually would.
I would agree for quite a long time. We had, you know,
we've always had the role of money in British politics is not new Lloyd George
basically sold honors, you know, to the highest bidder.
That's been a part of our system for a long time.
We've had cash for access cash for questions, but in general,
actually I would agree that the rules around our politics reasonably work
reasonably well when it comes to elections, there's really tight spending,
but in some ways actually that's an indication just how broken the system is.
The spending rules are so tight. It's about, on average,
about 12 to 15,000 pounds kind.
It's allowed to spend in each constituency that nobody keeps to them.
Nobody believes in Canada, general election spends that little.
So what we have actually is we all accept that those spending rules are going to
be broken. They're broken all the time. No one,
I think it's about a hundred years since the last person was convicted of
breaking spending rules during a general election, which is, is kind of,
that is a huge part of the problem. So we,
and in a world of kind of constant campaigning,
we have a political roots that are all set review around elections,
around electoral events, but in a world of constant campaigning,
which is kind of where we're at now in Britain. It's, uh, you know,
you just have to look at how our government docs in general,
that we have rolling political campaigns, the role of money then becomes way,
way harder to track.
And the way money brings influence into politics inspire for our heart.
If you, if you, if you wanted to give someone one example, uh,
to change their mind, to say something in your book, just look at this,
look at this, and then think again, what would you pick? Well.
I think I might take two examples just to be, just to be.
Here.
What is a really thank you very much. That is very generous.
One's a really simple one.
So if you get a lead for trigger your door front a politician election time,
it'll have probably their face looking smiling, maybe holding a baby,
seeing something on a dime. As I love on the back, it'll have their details.
And let's say who paid for new prints and all the rest.
So that's called an imprint.
All physical pieces of election paraphernalia have to have an imprint.
If that same politician was to send you a target out on Facebook saying the
exact same thing with exact same picture of themselves,
they don't have to say anything. They don't even have to carry an imprint on it.
Like that's not that we don't have to do that. They don't have to do that.
So that's a very, very kind of basic example of,
and that's not hard to fix that could be easily fixed,
but the decision is always has been taken not to fix it.
But if we wanted to put something which I think is more insidious and actually
more concerning,
I write quite a lot in the book about the role of a think tanks of what are
basically kind of corporate lobbying organizations in British politics.
And this is very American model of politics.
What you do is instead of funding politicians,
instead of giving politicians money,
what corporations and certain individuals who are interested in changing
official conversation do instead,
or as well as giving money to parties is to fund what looked like independent
groups who come up with recommendations and ideas and policies that fit in with
their agenda. This has long been a facet of American politics, you know,
building.
And who are, I mean,
you just want to migrate both bands or not treated or not cool
by their proper names by the media.
So before the last election you'd have Corbyn supporters from the
Vajra media, um, tore mean, excuse me, economic offense,
acting as outright,
outright propaganda for their parties.
And no one would say, hold on a second,
you are just repeating quality lines given to you by Jeremy Corbyn abolish guns.
That's what you are. You're not independent journalists. I think TennCare,
you are around propaganda because they, they, they, they, they want,
they closed along as the gang.
And a lot of these organizations like, uh,
the Institute of economic affairs and many of these Tufts and street groups,
there are also charities. So they even, it's like a double whammy.
You can give them sort of anonymously and get a charitable deduction on it.
And I think I completely agree what these art writers have done is CD
opportunities in the media space as well. A lot of these think tanks,
really what they are is very savvy media operations. They run phone lines.
If you pick up the phone and call them,
they will appear on your show to say pretty much whatever you want and what it's
done, what it does is it allows corporate influence to take,
to take hold and politics and ways we can see,
but it's also pulled and shifted our politics and our discourse in ways that
aren't representative. And I think I would agree if I turned,
when I turned on the television, the run-up to the 2019 general election,
the discourse has gone so far. It was so polarized for that very reason.
Yeah. Well, I mean,
they really do understand media because if you were running on boxing,
suppose someone watching this program, uh, publishes a piece,
say on Oakland democracy or in my newspaper, observe someone,
if someone's going to BBC polishing show phones,
not here's how the conversation goes. They'll say we really like your piece.
And the view view of you would say, Oh, thanks very much.
But would you say what you said, but then go on to just push it a bit far.
And if you actually want to know, I'm not sure that's true.
And then when you've pushed it a bit further,
will you push it to an absolutely absurd excrete?
Cause that's what we want on television.
And whether it's CIA on the foreign media or Claire Fox,
they all will say, yeah, of course we will.
We will go to the absolute extreme and provide you with a
gormless shrieking television that will stop the viewer. You know, rally,
make the viewer delighting or angry and stop them switching over or going off
and doing something. They really do understand how it works.
Well, does it, does it.
I call it a figure in my book and it's from the Institute to become confers own
report one year. And the IAA has a turnover. Most years of interim,
2 million pounds where the money comes from,
we really have no idea beyond the odd leak.
It's come from all the money in the past, back the money,
but we don't know much about it,
but it estimated it had 66 million pounds or to media and not one year.
That's a huge return for your investment. If I was,
why would you pay a lobbyist?
Who's going to have to have often registered a lobbying register who might get
you a meeting with a minister. It'd be there in the paper.
You have to look it up. You're much better. It's a better use of your money.
I would imagine spend a couple of grand with someone like that,
who will argue your point on television probably writes it in the newspaper
column, write a quick thin report that you can go around, you know,
go to gambling industry or wherever else. And you know,
and they will say in their defense, they would say, look,
we believe these things. Anyway, we're just saying what we believed,
but it's always interesting that what they say,
they believe tallies very closely with the kind of corporations that would want
to fund it.
You also give their backers plausible tonight, tonight.
That's what I find so fascinating about outriders, where long writes all that.
If they say something it's embarrassing, it's the party. They said, it's not us.
It's not us the party saying it's yes. So in shakes and the think tank, why,
why are you bothering us about it?
The same thing is happening with social media. Nick, I think too.
I think that's what's happened with social media.
Like I write in the book about the social media.
It started appearing around the 2019 general election.
You can push narrow shifts much further on social media with huge process
viability. You can just set up what are completely AstroTurf organizations.
You know,
I look at some like hundreds of thousands of pounds are spent on Facebook ads by
like groups from the left and from the right that disappeared.
As soon as the election ended, it's particularly on the right. It was, you know,
you're thinking, right you've you've spent,
there was one thing called capitalist worker spends about 65,000 pounds on
Facebook ads. You'd imagine at the end of that,
having won the election you'd want to celebrate.
You might want to harness those people who supported you.
Considering that you're saying you're a campaign, but yet no,
all of these groups,
every single one disappeared the day after the general election.
Real friends, organizations,
if you were a serious economic organization campaign group,
you wouldn't stop at the elections until you say no. Now, now, uh,
Johnson's in power. We want to give him ideas, hold him to account,
shape the debate.
You see that as the opportunity to actually, you know, to really engage,
you'd say, Oh, my word,
I've got all these supporters because what's interesting as well.
A lot of these campaigns have recorded no donations.
And so the donation threshold of 7,500 pounds.
So they're suggesting that they've got some of these campaigns.
If you'd spend 65,000 pounds on ads,
you go at least nine or 10 people to give you almost a maximum donation,
but just not enough to declare it, which to be honest, kind of beggars belief.
If you've not got the, where are you,
where did the idea that large numbers people are going to give money for?
What are, what are front organizations? It doesn't, it doesn't tally,
but there's no fear about doing that kind of thing because the chances of
anything ever happened to you are so slim. And if you were,
if the extra commission was to investigate you,
the maximum fine in Britain for breaking a lecturer is 20,000 pounds in America.
You can go to prison for breaking an extra law here barely even qualifies as a
slap on the wrist.
Yeah. Um,
so we've got a sort of 19th century,
early 20th century view of politics. It's just election campaigns,
very time controlled, but laws never enforced. Anyway,
we've got think tanks, front organization,
outriders who can operate particularly on social media,
basically beyond the rule of law, because there is no law covering them.
What else should we be worried about where else is dark money coming in?
There's also just traditional ways actually of just like even in just
traditional political donations, which do look like they're very transparent.
All political donations are, are, are, are, are, um, are registered,
but there's, there's still a problem with this. So for example,
the conservative party, which is the party that really relies on private money,
the labor party gets most of its money from the unions,
which has its own issues. But I.
Want to, in the interest of fairness, come back.
I'm very happy to have a kind of a chapter about that too.
But in terms of the conservative party, it's runs,
it runs what are called like an a two years of league of membership for
supporters. And this really happened during David Cameron.
It tried to diversify the amount of money to get into bill,
get more money instead of a thing called the leader's group for top Tory donuts.
If you give to conservative parties, it's 50,000 times a year,
you get to go once a quarter to meetings with the prime minister and leading
cabinet ministers. And you all kind of sit around, it's all off the record.
It's all private, nothing is nothing is divulged about what happens there.
That's incredible access for almost no money at David.
Carmen did come under pressure about this because he was holding hosts Indies in
Downing street and his flash, which was a government, a government residency,
relationally. He did start publishing these. But as I noticed,
when I was researching my book,
the conservative party has actually stopped publishing,
both stopped publishing any details of previous meetings and taken all the
records of the old ones off its website. So that's a really good example.
I think of how money can influence politics and really direct way. Um,
also what you're seeing is what is a lot of money.
I've spent a lot of time looking at the extra returns.
A lot of money comes from companies,
some of which seem to do almost no business and are very,
very opaque and hard to find out how they operate. You know,
I did a story recently about, there's not in Finch leaders,
a building,
which is about 50,000 companies registered and a number of companies have given
money to conservative party charity.
They are not actively doing business and national dress.
It's very hard to see what these companies do because some of them have almost
no turnover yet. They're still able to give money to political parties,
but there's that. So that's another way in which it's quite easy to, uh,
give them a,
to kind of funnel the money almost anonymously into political campaigns.
All the well, to me,
the most extraordinary story and the most English story of this is Russian
money, Russian influence in the Brexit referendum,
weekends up when we finally have a comms report on these
with something that is so disgustingly English,
it makes me want to abandon my nationality.
The security services didn't investigate. How would you, Oh, no,
we don't wash our dirty laundry in public.
We don't want to embarrass to raise an a,
we don't want to embarrass y'all y'all so be politically difficult.
So we'll pretend it didn't happen, which is remarkable considering
[inaudible] special powers because their officers are bravely out there risking
their lives.
And so they can have secret court hearings or official secrets acts protecting
them. Yeah.
The normal standards of justice and accountability thrown out the window to
protect these brave boys and girls, when a British referendum,
a British election there's allegations,
they've been interfered with little cows will close our eyes,
hide the eggs and say, are we stupid? Super difficult?
We won't do anything at all.
Well,
one of the things I found most remarkable about the Russia report is there's a
section in the middle where they basically the alters reports say we don't,
we never, when we were writing this,
we found it really hard to figure out who was in charge of looking after our
democracy. They could describe a democracy is a hot potential.
And it was quite clear that there's a bunch of different organizations,
none of whom had really taken responsibility for the kinds of things you were
talking about. Um,
this is a kind of Constantine might find them in the work ID where organizations
are regulations would pass the book from one to the other. Like we won't like,
you know, if I,
if I see an email between the extra commission and the information
commissioner's office, where each of them says,
this has nothing to do with us really it's the other one,
but that is writ large and the Russia report. And I couldn't,
I almost exact same time that report was being published and let's not forget
the government tried for eight months to suppress the report. And it was only,
you know, they tried everything to try and suppress that report,
but almost the exact same moment that was being that report was being finally
published. Chloe Smith, who's the cabinet office minister.
So she would be in charge.
Her brief should include things like exactly what we were talking about.
She was giving evidence to the PR or the separate parliamentary inquiry.
And she said, does a consolidation, electoral law reform, electoral law,
isn't the priority for the government.
So basically don't tend to do anything about any of these things.
And the only measure in terms of securing our democracy in our democratic
process that Boris Johnson has said he firmly wants to bring in is voter ID,
which is solving a problem that really doesn't exist.
Seven instance of voter ID at the 19 2017 general election.
So what you've got is, you know, you've got the security services you've got,
basically we haven't investigated what a huge question Mark about the democratic
process, which could happen again and again,
and instead it out there until we had the prime minister tilting at windmills.
Well, I mean, say what you liked about America,
but the CIA and the FBI did their duty.
They investigated a Russian interference in 2016 election,
and we know what they found.
We are pointed to the Facebook group set up to undermine Hillary Clinton.
We know, look junior in the song,
Japanese as a conduit for the Russians and Trump. We know if it will,
because it was investigated. Um, in Britain,
they ran away are all pass the buck, as you say, because, well,
uh, leave one of the Brexit referendum first arrays away,
then Boris Johnson support Brexit. Gotcha. Has politically difficult for us.
We could get into trouble. We'll just, we'll just, we'll just,
we'll just back off. I mean, she's a huge dereliction of duty, um.
Completely, I think.
And I think that that's writ large and I found the response was so
depressing in terms of, you know,
Boris Johnson stands up and says something that isn't in remainers and despite
having to things himself until quite recently, and it's all,
some sort of city plot. And I think that that sort of,
that aspect of elves kind of,
I've just really not caring about how degraded democracy is,
but in some respects, it is of a piece of what we saw in the last few months.
And then in the weeks and months leading up to the general election too,
like we did see a really dirty general election complaint. I think it's,
it's quite easy to forget.
It was one thing that I wanted to do writing this book was to kind of try and
put down in writing, like just the various things that we saw or whether it was,
you know, whether it was kind of, um, rebranding the conservative priorities,
Twitter, Twitter accounts,
to fact check your account during a live debate or just pushing,
arrive yourself on social media.
Do you, do you, um, I wanted to bounce. Do you have any worries?
Oh, do you see union funding for labor in the same typically it's business
funding through stories.
I'll tell you why I ask the question and it's not just as a matter of balance,
[inaudible] play a crucial role in getting its candidates, ed Miliband,
and the crucial role in getting Jenny foreign bla again,
Jeremy Corbyn directed after 2015,
it gets Len McCluskey gets, um, his friends,
United officials as general sexism. And I was just thinking,
well, if Maggie greed PLC the most evil capitalist company or
help select both to raise a may and Boris Johnson and then incest
executives and Beck agreed, went in and actually ran the tour reporting, um,
there'll be a bit of a fuss about it.
I think I do think there's a, there's, there's something interesting.
Like the union funding question, I think is one that the labor party,
because it hasn't ever diversified its funding, especially in recent years,
it's become, I think it has become an incredibly reliant on union funding.
And you end up with a question like the democratic relationship between what's
going on, what the unions, union funding and the labor party too, because,
you know, we've had seen ballots are very, very low numbers of, uh,
of return of returns and United and things like that.
And I think it's a reasonable question I would like to see to be honest,
like I think there's a reasonable case you made to just to capping donations
across the piece and saying, look, this is, this is, this is the most.
And the donation you can get from the individual,
this is the most you can get from this type of organization.
This is the most you can get from that type of organization.
And it's a controversial thing to suggest,
but actually getting the state to rename, to kind of come in behind. And, um,
I'm basically matched fond or more so small donations.
So if you were to move away from the reliance of the union of labor,
on the unions, on the Tories on very,
very small numbers of very rich people and actually force parties to diversify
their funding, they would, I think also be forced to diversify kind of how they,
how they operate and who they represent. You would see,
I think a much broader split.
You would get the chance to go back to far more broad church political parties.
If you cast back to the fifties and sixties, when both labor and the tourism,
millions and millions and millions of members, neighbors had had a big booth.
I did have a big jump out of Jeremy Corbyn became leader that seemed to trading
off mandatories a very small number of memory at the same numbers,
the SMP and these appear only in Scotland. So I think, and I,
the problem is in some respects,
the union funding of labor has encouraged labor to S to,
to not move at times is not diversified.
It's not democratized because there is always going to be a vested interest in
unions in, in controlling, if they're controlling the purse strings, well, then,
then you've got a huge amount of clouds.
I think your point that, you know, your controversial,
there's got to be more state funding because people don't like,
why should I pay my taxes to fund politics? But at the same time,
the same people who say that will then read your book or watch less than say,
Jesus Christ. Look at the corruption Peter's showing me, well,
you've got to have one or the other real, you've got to bite the bullet and say,
as most countries do well, you know, um, if you,
if you want an end to, or never read, but you also limit,
then you've got to accept that some but more taxpayer funding is, is in order.
That's why we don't realize how exceptional we are in some of this.
I think we do kind of tend to think that everywhere is the same as us and
especially with what we do. Like when I started doing this sort of work,
I used to think that Britain actually,
it wasn't so bad in Britain because compared to America,
it's far less money in Britain, like in America,
like you're 50,000 pounds would get you dinner with the prime minister.
I don't even fit in America $50,000. I'd probably get you, you know,
a minor Senator from, you know, from a Midwestern state, nevermind,
nevermind the leader of a country.
But if you think about it the other way around, actually it makes Britain,
I think even more sensible to finance because partly because there's less money
around, it's actually even more important to try and get it.
That's why I think like we, we toleration. So the conservatives tolerate,
you know, um, the wife of a former, um,
vitamin improved and finance minister spending 80, 90,
a hundred thousand pounds to pay tenants with Boris Johnson. You know, this is,
which is just,
I think we saw that in other countries you'd find absolutely jaw-dropping.
And I think it's really erodes trust in politics.
There was an interesting survey from Cambridge university this year that found a
disenchantment and dissatisfaction with democracy were highest in two places in
the world, the United States and great Britain.
I don't think it's a coincidence that there are two countries in which money
plays the biggest role. And it's like, we've seen even this summer,
a series of scandals from the cronies knowledge arcs that got given peerages and
knighthoods and new dissolution honors list to the Robert Genex apparent bias in
Richard property case. You know, there's, there's not,
it's it's to the Russia report itself.
There's no shortage of evidence of like, you know,
of basically a cronyism and what I think could only be called corrupt.
Well, it's an interesting point you make isn't it, um, uh, in Britain,
your bride goes further. You get, you get, you get a lot more for your money.
I will say things to just stop comparing ourselves in America, you know,
love daily lot should murder Tuesday, contrast his politics are fantastic.
You corrupt are openly correct.
Even corrupting. The sense of politics takes tens, hundreds,
and hundreds of millions of dollars. The Supreme court say,
you can take it from any in-class group they want, you want, they can run packs.
That's how America works.
It's not how the overwhelming majority of Western democracies work
in most Western democracies. As you say, you cannot. If you are a,
the wife of the leading Russian faker,
give the prime minister's party 80,000 pounds and have, uh,
have friendly tendencies match with him, you know.
We wouldn't be allowed. It would be, it would be a huge scandal.
It will be a kind of thing that ended careers.
And I think that's part of it too, is that I think in recent years,
our tolerance we've become quite,
you're newer to the kind of scandals that I think in the past would have cost
political career. So in my,
so I used to go back to the story of Liam Fox and Atlantic bridge,
and we won't rehearse all of it here,
but the long and short was being Fox spent 10 years building up this Atlanta
cyst think tank between Britain and America.
He got funding from all sorts of who knows where set up a sister organization,
America to, to pull in more money. And, but when he became minister,
he became sexually safe for defense, which is a high-profile position.
And he had, uh, he had his, um, his AIDS coming and go, um,
his best friend and head of the same charity, Atlantic bridge,
going around the world with him and meeting foreign dignitaries and foreign, uh,
you know, and making senior foreign, um, kind of political leaders.
And that did events that did cost Liam Fox.
But I actually think of that scandal that happened now,
a I think it probably wouldn't, it wouldn't have been as down.
It wouldn't have been anywhere near as in his political career,
but also at that stage, all the newspapers really ran for that story.
It wasn't just one paper. They all went into it together.
And I think there's been like as, as almost immediate,
immediately become polarized too. There's been less of a tendency. You know,
the guardian wouldn't really go for these sorts of stories.
People like NATO Moxie, we go for them.
But often actually this kind of stuff has become, it's not,
it's not been focused on as much. The rush report,
I think was the first time in awhile where you've seen things like, you know,
Russian donors in the front page of the times and things like that.
Well, I mean,
I think you're quite right about the totalization particular Brexit is that if
you were a lever,
all matters about a politician was [inaudible] nothing else
mattered.
There was a time to go from money to sex and keep the scope
bubbling along.
The conservative party of all parties would never have had the lecture like
Boris Johnson as a leader.
They might've been filled with a queasy Victorian sexual hypocrisy or what have
you. But as you just said, no, no, no, uh, you're a scoundrel.
We don't want you. And you'll known to be a scoundrel.
And I think the same applies with money. Now, you know,
this is what drives me mad on, uh, Russia in 2016 where, you know,
colleagues of mine like Carol Cadwalader actually got,
I would have the Russian ambassador meeting.
Um, Aaron Banks,
Nigel Farrage offers of goldmines in Siberia during the
referendum campaign or the referendum campaign. And it's still,
as far as the right-wing press,
because it's not a story because it's anti Brexit.
And so it was a BBC who just as bad as [inaudible], Oh,
it's too hot for us to touch. You know,
I'd say a handful of journalists, if you Luke Harding,
Carol Cairo that have been left out there,
often abuse and have done the work that should have been done
by a well-organized properly run liberal democracy.
How it, you know, you can't, you can't leave it to journalists.
So I don't think I don't want to talk to a,
our trade down because we don't have subpoena powers. You know,
you can't say, you can't say, well, this, this looks so wrong.
I'm going in with my team. I want to get in the searches bank accounts,
you have no power to do that.
You have no rights to that only the state can do the job and the state's not
what students yell.
Yes and no, I would agree just there is a limit to the power of journalism.
That's what journalism can do is put something out into the public domain,
but it needs to stay to act on it. It needs political actors to act on it.
And what you saw in the, in the, in the kind of the closest we got was,
was the kind of, um,
was the department of culture media in support select committee inquiry to fake
news, which, which actually generates a lot of interesting stuff,
but really that was just a talking shop. It was not, it had no official powers.
Dominic Cummings, numerous times refused to come and give evidence.
It didn't matter a to two dominant comments. And he was still,
he made special advisor to borrows Johnson,
despite refusing to appear before parliament a couple of months later.
So it's quite true. I think that's the things that culture,
there's no comeback for people for bending the rules until they break.
There's no need for them to engage unless they're on a lesser is something
rigorous with actual proper subpoena powers,
with proper powers to Dem of democratic oversight,
to go and investigate these sorts of things. And they are the kind of questions.
It doesn't in my mind as well, you know? Okay.
The Russia report is written just by Russia, but this, you know,
you could ask about Chinese influence.
You could also ask about the influence of individual donors. You might want,
you know, nuns does a huge amount. I mean,
if we're not going to ask those questions, well,
we're never going to find out the answers.
Well, I mean,
that's the point there's worth making everyone refers back to 2016,
the Trump election, the Brexit referendum, but you know,
we're talking four or five years ago.
Now the world has moved on and there were all kinds of countries
now, uh, following Russian information warfare,
you still trying to start it with trying to cover up its failures on the COVID
virus, Iran, Saudi Arabia,
all kinds of countries are piling into the avenues with
social media or growing forward.
So it's not as if it's not as if we ought to be looking,
are we fighting battles? Um,
because we haven't.
And as far as the establishment forums,
a better word has no willingness to change and put proper protections in
place where we're even more exposed. So I think as we go forward, yeah.
I would agree. No, I think if anything where even because, I mean,
because I think of the response from Boris Johnson to the Russia report,
it's actually really denigrated.
I think the opportunity to even talk about these things,
because he's basically said, I do not want to hear about,
so if you're a government minister say you're a government who thinks this is a
big deal.
I actually ended up on the radio a couple of days after Russia reports with
Tobias, Alberta conservative convention. And, you know, he was in,
this is really, this is concerning. We should,
we need to find out more about this. We need to be investigating it. Well,
you know, he's basically, you know,
I can't imagine that would have gone down particularly well in Downing street,
where there were basically the only,
the only people are going to say things about this are people who really are
like twice I would, who voted remain. And it will be seen not as parts of a job.
It's like, well,
my political career is not going to go anywhere for a moment anyway,
so I can talk about it. But if you were in a position of it's our,
like a government departmental minister, well,
then you're not going to engage with it because it will be,
it'll be disastrous for your career.
Yeah. Yeah. I keep me reminded of a little couple. Of course,
it's Elizabeth, the first Rose, um, freezing, never prospers.
What's the reason perfect prospers. Non-dairy Couric, treason,
no one in power Daz call out or demand the
laws, uh, that we need because,
uh, the people, uh, you know,
Boris Johnson and the people that want it.
No. And so, so exactly. And so in that, in, in that vacuum,
you get kind of quite fast or things like what's happening at the moment where
you have the commission on standards and public life is having an investigation
and that kind of an inquiry into lecturer law and electoral reform,
but it's not going to include money in politics or party place donation.
So you will tinker around the edges and come up with small little bits and
pieces, but there won't be any substantive change at all. And if anything,
actually, it's quite not hard to see the system getting more.
Okay. I want to end with two questions,
what you think should happen and what you think will happen.
So if you were prime minister, as you probably should be,
what would you do? What laws would you enact?
I will, I will, um,
I'll resist the temptation to kind of on the idea of the first Irish prime
minister of England. That would be a WTF that will be the full reversal,
but it's well, there's lots of things that we did quite quickly learn.
Aren't hard, you know, I would reform electoral law quite dramatically.
It's not hard to do other countries do it.
They do it like there's models out there.
It doesn't have everything doesn't have to be world vision.
It can be word copying. You know, there's not hard to lift laws.
And so basically, and some of us come from that,
like actually America have a proper, a proper lobbying registered.
It actually works or all the lobbying is there,
but unlike America put a seeding on political donations, make it quite little,
maybe about 10,000 pounds, seven and a half thousand euros in France.
So something like that make party membership, tax deductible, which,
you know,
is quite an easy way of putting money into Pilates to priorities and increasing
the number of people in politics without, you know, without pausing the break,
uh, kind of touching that,
the idea of giving actual money to police departments and politicians does.
So there's a bunch of things like that. I think the internet is a huge thing.
I think it's beyond just a scope of one stage.
I think the power of Silicon Valley and tech companies to dictate how our
politics works and how democracy works is really is quite, is really terrifying.
In many respects, especially companies like Facebook, you show, you show,
you flirt with the morality to be, to be, to be polite about it.
And I think there's a real need for politicians, um, to, to act,
to act collectively honest and to build coalitions and actually your husband
very good on, on this European union has been good on,
on Facebook and just the size of tech companies and the role that they play
in our democracy. I think that's something that isn't,
that is a nettle that really does need to be grabbed. So like in the book,
I talk about what happened with the railroad in the like late 19th century,
where you had these parents and you had this kind of basically what was a
captive, a captive capitalism, capitalism,
and that's bad for everybody.
And they were broken up and politics was actually really arranged around that.
Like there was actual political candidates who stood on platforms like that.
And I think there's a whole, that's a huge thing that I think needs to happen.
There needs to be a huge kind of political will to do something on it.
So that's all the nice, you know, when I'm King, uh, when I'm the Irish,
the Irish English. Yeah. So
not being the prime minister when I'm kind of looking around just as,
as, as, as the reporter and the punter. I, I do find that like,
it's hard not to it's,
it's definitely hard to discover and to not see at the moment in particular
around reform, coming through government, that's quite,
I find that quite difficult to see because of the steps,
because what this government is seen as I can get away with doing things,
you know,
I've spent the last few months actually reporting a lot on government contracts
and how government contracts have basically gone to meet at the conservative
party with no tendering process, you know, really lucrative.
And when you're able to do that, and there's no political comeback,
I think why would you, why would you try and set set?
Why would you try and fix a system that benefits you when the rig system
benefits you? Why would you try and fix it? So gloomy part off that.
So I think what their needs almost be is like some sort of way in which actual
citizens and actual individuals are able,
whether it's engaging with tech companies and making, making, like, you know,
whether it's kind of saying,
like putting advertisement from things like Facebook to say,
look on while you're going to still run political ads that are for spreading
lies. Well then, you know,
we're not going to advertise which a dark can be part of the solution,
but I also think another practice solution is, is,
is that taking that to a democratic level as well, it's going right for,
for MPS, for individual MPS who are found guilty of doing instead,
it becomes something that isn't just forgotten about. And isn't,
doesn't just move on from that. Like, so you do end up continuing on this is,
you know, this is, this is who this is what's happened and making that,
you know,
making that an actual point that that's just reiterated over and over again,
but it is, I'm not, I'm not Panglossian.
I do realize that in the current climate,
as long as politicians think they can get away with the only way around that is
making the public say something, say that this isn't, you know, that politicians
will not tolerate.
[Inaudible] the mood is going to change. I thought you were,
you were quite right from what you said earlier about, well, look,
any scandal will be tolerated, would not even be a scandal,
uh, to say supporters of leave.
If the politician century was a leader,
because what mattered to them was leaving the EU.
Everything else was diversity and could always be dismissed though.
It's just moaning remain is trying to get involved. Now that's fading,
uh, people's incomes,
people's jobs are going up in smoke because of the COVID crisis.
And that is a, um,
there is a very bad smell about this government. Uh, anything goes,
uh, smell of entitlements. Um, I,
I thought the most interesting thing about it is partly the same as what your
book's about, but about DMing, Dominic Cummings
was all he needed to do. When the guardian in the mirror broke.
The story on the Friday was, well,
he could have resigned that would have killed the story drops.
You sort of get set you're out. But if he, even if he has a college,
there is such an aggressive maps show.
We are the masters now culture in this government, you never conceived an end.
You never apologize. You never recreate you. Uh, whatever it is,
whatever it is is where you've done. We can always say, Oh yes,
remain as this guest repeats. It's just our enemies making this up. We can,
in the case of Dominic Cummings, even for his own blog posts to make it look,
he's so essential, he saw COVID-19 coming. Um,
I wonder how the optimist in me, I'm not usually twos are being optimists. Yes.
One does this,
how long this one will luckily decadent periods of English history can last,
before people start turning, particularly people whose incomes and tattoos,
jobs are going there's relatives might have died of COVID how long they were put
out.
It was interesting. I thought,
I thought the dominant calming thing was bearings.
And especially when you sort of polling around us, you know, uh,
lots of voters were really unhappy with a lot of leave.
Voters were really unhappy with it.
And the government tried to frame it as a leave remain thing, you know,
in the guard in America, you know, campaigning remaining newspapers.
And I don't think that worked and as it did.
And if you look at the polls, it really didn't.
And that I think is going to be almost unsustainable position.
Say in six months time, you know, after January, I think it's going to be very,
very hard to frame everything. It's a breakfast of your conspiracy, you know,
as a, as a romaine conspiracy, no idea. I would agree.
I think there's more reasons to be cheerful.
If you look at the kind of polling data without comparing America to Britain,
I think it's easy to over compare the two, the two places.
It's easy to see too much of a bleed over from one to the other.
Even though my book, I talk a lot about those links.
And I think there's definitely in terms of money and politics a lot going on,
but the two societies are fundamentally actually really different.
I've lived in both of them and they really are very different.
And I think we're not at that level of cultural Wars here where if Boris Johnson
stands up and says black is white, everyone will go. Yeah, of course. You know,
at least there's a lot of people who won't and it's still,
and I think there is actually in that respect. I do think there's reasonable.
Be careful. Right. Um, thank you so much.
And I'd like to end by saying everyone watching she'll go out and buy a copy of
this book, preferably with their own money, not corrupt money, not stolen money,
but I'm thought Peter will accept any sales. Um, uh, thank you.
And thank you very much for, uh, uh, depressing,
but still invigorating conversation.
Thank you very much and time. Thanks for making me imagine myself as a, as the,
as the prime minister one day.